en medio de lisboa estos portugueses
acuden todos los días a este vehículo
son antiguos pero inhumanos que vienen
para recibir una dosis de droga
sintética
número 51 70
estoy pidiendo una dosis de metadona
estoy mi número para que me la den así
puedo seguir teniendo una vida normal de
metadona sustituto de la heroína no
podría hacer nada
1300 personas acuden diariamente a dos
furgonetas que se encuentran en la
capital
ya no consumo drogas ya no bebo y puedo
hablar con el médico que está aquí
además de la metadona los consumidores
reciben un acompañamiento médico y
psiquiátrico este profesional ha podido
comprobar la eficacia del sistema las
infecciones de vih ligadas a las
jeringas no esterilizadas han disminuido
a lo largo de los últimos 20 años
antes el 60 por ciento de las personas
que venían tenían sida ahora sólo el 14
por ciento de los pacientes son
seropositivos es una gran diferencia
que estas furgonetas son gestionadas por
asociaciones pero financiadas por el
estado son un símbolo de la estrategia
por la que optó portugal descriminalizar
el consumo de drogas desde hace 20 años
la policía solo persigue los traficantes
los consumidores ahora monitoreados se
presentan a audiencias en centros
conocidos como comisiones para la
disuasión en promedio con cuánta
frecuencia consume drogas no ha vuelto a
consumir nada desde la última vez
aquí el equipo evalúa los factores de
riesgo el objetivo proponer un
tratamiento personalizado en caso de ser
necesario
a través de esta audiencia podemos
verificar los hechos y que la droga sea
para consumo personal
también debemos evaluar los hábitos de
consumo
el entorno familiar o si la persona
trabaja o no
este hombre portaba cocaína cuando fue
requisado por la policía
debe haber más atención y control me
parece bueno que nos ayuden aquí
este portugués no es un adicto sino un
consumidor de drogas de uso recreativo
así que no se le propone ningún
tratamiento y no se le hará seguimiento
sin embargo la despenalización no
implica una legalización y
sigue siendo una infracción aún es
ilegal es guardamos los expedientes aquí
otra vez cinco años durante estos cinco
años el proceso legal se puede reanudar
si un consumidor regresa en ese caso
puede enfrentarse a una multa de hasta
700 38 dólares pero nunca una pena de
cárcel esta estrategia fue creada en
2001 cuando la heroína ha causado
estragos en el país según cálculos uno
de cada diez portugueses la consumía en
esa época alexandre quintanilla presidía
la comisión que creó la ley audaz
trabajamos unos cuatro meses y medio
seis o siete meses después el gobierno
lado todo sin hacer ninguna educación
ha sido aprobado de manera unánime en
votación final teníamos nuestro trabajo
aprobado de manera unánime terminamos
nuestro trabajo
no es un problema de izquierda o de
derecha la ideología no ayuda mucho en
estos casos hay que ver el problema y
entenderlo para poder resolverlos
el cambio de paradigma ha dado resultado
la tasa de mortalidad por consumo de
drogas en portugal es cinco veces más
baja que el promedio europeo sin embargo
este sistema sigue siendo único en el
continente tal como se comprueba en el
observatorio europeo de las drogas y
toxicomanías
no las comisiones para la disuasión no
son dependientes del ministerio de
justicia del interior
es el único país europeo tal vez el
único en el mundo
donde el consumidor
un panel de profesionales dependiente
del ministerio
portugal solo se ha demorado en
implementar un aspecto de esta política
las salas de consumo supervisado
conocidas como narcosalas la primera
abrió este año en un barrio de bajos
recursos de la capital paulo trabaja
allí
esta es la sala de consumo abrirá en 10
minutos estamos verificando que todo
esté en orden para poder empezar los
consumidores de heroína cocaína y crack
vienen varias veces al día realmente
hacía falta este centro para que los
portugueses entendieran que necesitamos
dignidad en nuestro nadie alegre a pesar
de la serie de medidas propuestas por
las autoridades paulo ha podido
constatar que desde su apertura en mayo
esta sala tiene una demanda mucho mayor
de la que se había previsto
al principio pensábamos que vendrían
unas 200 personas y final del año
en este momento vienen casi doscientas
personas al día
según él se necesitan más salas como
esta a diferencia de la heroína con la
metadona la cocaína y el crack no tienen
sustitutos y el número de consumidores
sigue aumentando al igual que en el
resto de europa